Let's work on forming the /ɝ/ sound.
Make sure that your tongue is bunched and tense in the middle.
Release the sound around the bunched portion and the slightly lifted front of the tongue.
It should be held for a longer duration than the unstressed /ɝ/ sound,...
...which occurs at the end of words like "father", "brother".
/ɝ/, /ɝ/, /ɝ/.
Here's /ɝ/ in the beginning of some words.
Earth, Urgent, Irk.
And here it is in the middle.
Bird, Heard, Learning.
Here it is at the end of some words.
Fur, Purr, Sir.
Listen to these pairs of words to hear the contrasting sounds.
Earl, All.
Birth, Bath.
Purse, Pass.
Here are some sentences that use the /ɝ/ sound.
We heard the birds in the fir tree.
Learning about the Earth is urgent.
/ɝ/, /ɝ/, /ɝ/.
Nice work!